everyone who has joined us today
it's lovely to see you all here and
as sonalika
very accurately mentioned that we are
going to
indulge more into this
wonderful topic of astrobiology or
spaceonomics and i'm pretty much sure
that every one of you who is present
here today is
interested and enthusiastic and you're
well aware of the various kinds of
research going on around the world
there are also numerous opportunities
which are early career as well as
for the more experienced ones
be it a postdoctoral fellow or
a scientist position available for
various people all across the globe to
grab this opportunity
to help people do that and
announce yourself in the domain of
astrobiology we at findbiotic have
organized this particular opportunity
for all of you where
every one of you can get an opportunity
to indulge in your own independent as
well as team
projects
where you would also receive
mentor support one-on-one guidance and
available course materials which would
help you to learn all along the way as
you go
and if you have joined us for the first
time there was another webinar which was
done and in that webinar me and my
colleagues have discussed in detail
about
what are the topics that we are going to
cover what is astrobiology all about
what is our focus and what is our aims
and in today's
webinar which is more of like a
discussion we will be discussing about
all the project ideas that you guys have
and what are your aspirations
we would also
discuss about potential teams you guys
can form teams amongst yourself those
who are already here or if you have a
research lab or a team who would be
interested you can also invite them and
today we will be discussing about where
to find the data sets what the data
looks like and how can you
start your own project just by sitting
at your home
this is a pandemic
era where it's very difficult to get
hold of a laboratory to go to the fields
and do the research work
same thing kind of problem everyone is
facing all around the world but
we can't stop right we have to go on
doing our own projects and
coming up with the publication
participating in conferences and
therefore this sort of a model where you
can actually get involved in
practical works right from your home
remotely provides you an exciting
opportunity to be a part of bigger
consortiums and groups just by sitting
at your home
so before i move on to the further
discussions i would like to show you
guys about what the entire plan is how
it looks like and what is
the plan all together so i guess you
guys can see my screen so this is the
home page of the program which is called
introduction to space comics
and this program is actually designed
you to help you through your research
project now there are several
steps in defining a project and getting
it done for example it begins with
finding a good data set a data set which
is worthy of looking deeper into to
curate it to label it properly and to
make it ready the second part
is obviously the analysis part
the methodologies that you have to use
and how you're going to use it
what is the appropriate methods that you
should
apply for your expected results
now once you get the hold of the results
how do you understand if the results are
a good result or a bad one or what
do you biologically interpret from those
data and how can it correlate with
whatever
is have been happening or going on in
the biological body
so
these are the various challenges which
many students face in today's world um
whatever background you belong and
whatever your expertise might be these
are the problems are the challenges
which most of the people face and that's
why we have designed this particular
curriculum to help you understand what
we are going to talk about and what is
it all about
so to begin with the first day would be
focus towards the topic of astrobiology
what is it all about what are the
various subtypes as you can see on this
screen
we will be also discussing about the
theories of origin of life
and
the various topics or debates currently
going on in this particular domain
the next day which is on october 25th we
would be
diving deeper into
the concept of origin of life because
i'm sure that many of you are interested
in actually analyzing or understanding
the origin of life better and you want
to start some projects of your own use
in this particular aspect of origin of
life
so we would give you some idea about how
you can
gather data what sort of data should you
look into what are the concepts that you
can analyze definitely we would be
talking about extremophiles because
you all must agree that
extremophiles are
very very important
in the understanding of origin of life
or not as well as in the concept of
hoping for life beyond earth
and we would just
not give you another lecture but also
give talk about the data sets how does
it look like where you can find them and
also give you certain project examples
which uses ancient rna reconstruction or
protein remodeling and
what results have they got and what can
you guys do as a part of your project
and this is not something which is very
rare like many research groups are
actually doing
marvelous research in this particular
domain
then uh the third
day would be focused more towards the
other aspect of astrobiology which is
space flight travel
so as you would agree that
in the current ada with the commercial
space flight agencies coming to the
forefront traveling to spaces increased
manifolds
and with the increase in the number of
missions to space the risks of
astronauts getting affected by the
various factors of space flight is also
increasing rapidly
for example space flight is made up of
various factors like
microgravity ionizing radiation
and isolation that has an effect on
their brain
so
before we plan a mission
to mars or maybe even the moon which are
long-term missions it becomes mandatory
to completely understand the effects of
these conditions on
the genome and
the expression of genes the gut
microbiome of the astronauts and
we need to make sure that they won't
suffer from any chronic illness like
answer when they are on that particular
mission
to do that it's the right time to
actually get hold of these sort of data
sets and
start analyzing them and believe me or
not there are various organizations in
the world who are looking into this
particular domain and they want people
to get involved in this sort of
projects
to give you an example there's
one conference which is coming up next
month and it's focused towards space
health and the peaceful use of space
technologies
so you can understand by the title
itself that people are all around the
world are actually talking about this
particular thing so it's the best
opportunity for us to get involved in
these sorts of conferences and other
opportunities by having a project of our
own
so that's what we will be talking about
and on the fourth day
since fine biotech
focuses on bioinformatics how to utilize
the various comics data to your project
we would be giving you a thorough
explanation of all the omics levels like
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics and also multi-omics
integration
this
comics levels were studied in the nasa
twin study as mentioned by sanatika
but here's the benefit of doing it with
us
first first of all you don't need to
have any coding skills many students who
are biologists like me have a problem
with coding
that's a big hurdle but here you don't
need to code why
because here you would get all the
algorithms just
in a point and click interface
so you don't need to know about any of
these algorithms what's behind that what
are the codes you just have to see this
particular user interface which prompts
you helps you with
every detail which pops up on the screen
and you just have to click point and
click and you can build the entire
pipeline i will be giving you other
examples as well and show you
how to do it
and
excuse me
so the final day that is the day five
would be again focused towards
uh projects because that's the day when
you guys need to come up or decide on
your projects and finalize what are you
going to working work on from this
particular day so this day i would be
giving you other examples of projects
and
walking you through my project how i do
it how i did it and what are
what uh my project looks like even today
i would be showing you some examples and
on this day we will discuss with you all
your
confusions or doubts and
from this particular day you would get
the opportunity to work on your own
project and you would be meeting the
mentors twice a month
so you would be getting the support you
can show them all your results consult
with them and
that final target of course is to come
up with a good result which you can
publish if it is excellent
if not
publishing just now you can definitely
take it to a conference
as a poster or an oral presentation
so
let me give you an example of the
various projects that has been already
done by the people who have participated
in the previous programs so as you can
see here this is my project here
and if i scroll down you would see that
various other people have submitted
their projects which they have completed
with fine so you can see these research
questions and they are the ones which
are going around in the world of biotech
right now so here you can see the in
silico analysis of affected biological
pathways in multiple sclerosis
transcriptomic analysis of cd4 plus t
cells so
every
project that has been done here has been
either published in a peer-reviewed
journal or has been taken to a
conference and
several students have won several prizes
in fact
so let me walk you through one of the
projects and show you how it looks like
so the project here if you go through
you would find that it's a
well-structured interface where you
would find a brief overview you would
find details about the data sets you can
check it out
and these are all submitted to the
harvard repository you can visit them
and analyze them yourself
then comes the abstract part where you
would explain your project in brief as
you guys know the structure of a
peer-reviewed journal paper basically is
similar
so once you submit your project in this
particular manner over here
it gets very easy to take it to a
publication or to take it to
any conference because everything that
you need is ready
so it looks really interesting right
so before we move on to you guys and
discuss with you what are your interests
and
i will also show you some
techniques to analyze it and some
pipelines that i have created but before
moving on to that we have with us
from turkey and she has been one of
those participants whom about whom i was
talking about and she has
already done a project in this
particular domain of astrobiology where
she has analyzed the radiation threats
and the effects of radiation ionizing
radiation on the gut microbiome of
astronauts
and
she has also taken her
project to a preprint publication and
i'm sure she is looking for submitting
it into a peer-reviewed journal so
it's the best opportunity to have a look
and learn from her have a look at her
project and learn from her how was her
experience of the project how did she
utilize the platform of divine food in
bang and
what's this what's her entire experience
because it's a similar kind of
experience that you guys are also going
to experience in just a few days so hi
dilara
over to you now
hello thank you for that introduction